so we'll start from the daily wire it
says
netflix and tick tock announced on
sunday that they have
suspended their services inside russia
following russian president vladimir
putin's decision to invade ukraine
netflix said in a statement given the
circumstances on the ground we decided
to suspend our service in russia
the verge added last week netflix said
it wouldn't comply with a new russia law
that requires large streamers to host 20
russian propaganda channels such as ntv
and the state-backed channel one
the state-backed channel one is what
it's called the streaming giant later
announced that it's halting all
productions and acquisitions in russia
uh netflix have been working on four
russian originals at the time
netflix currently has around one million
subscribers in russia so all of them are
out of luck now then tick tock announced
on sunday that it was also suspending
its services inside russia for safety
reasons
uh they said tick-tock is an outlet for
creativity and entertainment that can
provide a source of relief and human
connection during a time of war when
people are
facing immense tragedy in isolation
according to the company's statement
however our highest priority is the
safety of our employees and our users
and in light of russia's new fake news
law we have no choice but to suspend
live streaming and new content to our
video service in russia while we review
the safety implications of this law now
the first thing that you think is uh
okay they got rid of
uh netflix they don't have tick tock
this is actually in many ways
the best thing that could happen to the
russian people in a lot of ways uh next
thing you know like mcdonald's and all
the fast food giants are gonna are gonna
boycott russia as well
and that's when it really backfires
because now russia becomes the strongest
and healthiest country in the entire
world because these are the the this is
the only country these companies won't
go and go into but it also raises the
question of um
okay netflix is suspending its
service
in russia
first of all
how is that how does that punish putin
exactly
so i guess that means putin can't go on
and binge watch tiger king but something
tells me he's not worried about doing
that right now so if it punishes anybody
it punishes the people in russia and
nobody else
and if we're doing that if we are if we
are
punishing the people in a country
because of what their governments are
doing
and if these major corporations are
taking these
this this kind of stand
then
what about netflix service in china
uh what about tick tock in china the
chinese government essentially runs tick
tock so we we certainly know that they
still have tick tock in china
what about that and if you really want
to
extend this logic as far as it will go
when you're punishing the people for
what their governments are doing i don't
know if uh i don't know if any of us are
going to be safe at the end of that
certainly we've got to take netflix out
of canada as well
just to start with but it doesn't end
there i'm going back to the daily wire
report it says numerous financial
service companies announced over the
weekend that they were suspending uh
operations in russia as well due to the
invasion american express announced on
sunday that they were suspending all
operations in russia and then
it was visa
pulled out mastercard
all of these companies are saying we're
not going to operate in russia anymore
as far as i know this is the first time
we've seen anything like this with all
of these major companies all at once
suspending operations in an entire
country
in uh
in revenge out of vengeance for what
that government is doing
and the follow-up to the story by the
way of all the
financial organizations pulling out of
russia is that as i was just reading a
different headline is that now russia is
turning to china to make up for all of
this
so you can't have visa you can't have
mastercard now they're going to go to
for all their banking needs and all
their financial needs now they're going
to rely on china even more than they did
before
how does that help us how does that help
the west in the long run
to send russia and russians uh fleeing
even more into the arms of china
so when we start punishing the people of
russia i
uh i know how that can hurt i can
imagine all the ways that i will hurt
strengthening the bond between russia
and china which we don't want
turning russians against the west even
more
um when they already it seems
there's there's a strong anti-war
contingent and feeling among russians
at least based on what we're being told
by western media that this this war is
unpopular in russia as it is
so you could flip that sentiment against
you
that's the bad that that's the bad thing
that can happen okay that's the negative
that's the loss
but what's the win
what's the advantage
what do we gain from this is my question
and i i can't help but uh keep going
back to this this point here that
uh after 9 11
we were constantly warned like the very
next day
uh the the one of the first priorities
one of the number one priorities after 9
11 was to make sure that there was no
islamophobia
in fact prior to 9 11 i'm not sure i
even ever heard the phrase islamophobia
after 9 11 is when it is when it became
mainstream
and we kept hearing about this problem
of islamophobia so we were very in our
in our country there was this intense
focus on making sure
that uh
regular muslim people
are not held responsible for what some
muslims did
and then you fast forward a little bit
and china
uh
invents a virus in a lab unleashes it on
the world one way or another kills five
million people and again what's one of
the first things we hear
that we we can't have
anti-asian hate has to stop
you know there's a plague of anti-asian
hate which is an even bigger epidemic
even bigger plague than covet itself
to so much as call
uh the coronavirus the china virus
is itself an act it's a hate crime
against asians
and yet with with russia
now all of a sudden it's yeah hold hold
hold them all accountable
punish all russian people
go and vandal there's russian
restaurants and stores here vandalize
them no big deal
why is that it would almost seem as
though the idea is that um because
russian people are perceived as white
even though a great many of them really
are not but they're perceived as white
and so therefore it's bigotry against
them and punishing them for what their
government is doing is okay whereas you
could never do that against the chinese
people because they're not white well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content